- [Instructor] We are
told we want to solve
the following equation,
the negative natural log of two x
is equal to two times the absolute value
of x minus four, all of that minus seven.
One of the solutions is x is equal to 0.5.
Find the other solution.
They say hint, use a graphing calculator
and round your answer
to the nearest tenth.
So pause this video and have
a go at this if you like,
and then we'll work on this together.
And I encourage you to have a go on it,
(laughing) a go at it.
All right now let's work on this together.
Now the key here is to
realize that we might be able
to solve this by graphing,
or at least approximate the
solutions to this by graphing.
And the way we do that is,
if we have an equation,
especially a hairy equation
like this, in one variable,
we can set y equal to the left
and then set y equal to the right
and then graph each of those functions
and then think about where they intersect.
Because they'll intersect at an x-value
that gives us the same y-value,
and that means that the
two sides are the same.
So what do I mean by that?
Well we could set y is equal
to the negative natural log of two x.
So we could have one equation
or one function like that.
And then we could have
another equation or function
that y is equal to two times
the absolute value of x
minus four minus seven.
And let's see where they intersect.
And the x-values where they intersect,
those are going to be solutions to that.
So I'm going to use Desmos
as my graphing calculator.
So let's type in the two sides.
So first I'll do the left side.
So if y is equal to the negative
natural log of two x.
And actually, let me make
my color to be the same
or as close as I can, so maybe
closer to that bluer color.
Okay and then the net
one, I want y is equal
to two times,
two times the absolute value,
actually I don't know
whether Desmos prefers,
I'll use that, actually that works, okay,
x minus four, and then I
will close my absolute value,
and then I have minus seven.
And I will do this in the red color
so that we can keep track of things.
Okay.
So those are my two graphs.
And now, I just need to think
about where they intersect.
And one of the solutions
is x equal to 0.5.
That's not the one they want.
They want the other solution so to speak.
So let's see.
So let's see, we have one solution,
actually let me zoom in a little bit.
So when x is equal to
0.5, that's this solution,
that's this solution right over here.
It looks like y is equal to zero there.
But then the other point of intersection
seems to be right over here,
and actually Desmos has
a nice little feature
where it'll tell us that
point right over there.
But you could even approximate it.
You can see that x is over six
and that each of these,
let's see one, two, three,
four, five, each of those is .2.
So it's going to be 6.2 something
is what I would do, and
they want us to round
to the nearest tenth anyway.
So you don't even need
to use that feature,
but you can see very
clearly that when x is equal
to approximately 6.238,
that we get a y is equal to negative 2.54.
Or another way to think about it is,
when x is approximately equal to,
when x is approximately equal to 6.2,
that the two sides of this equation
are going to be equal to each other,
are approximately equal to each other.
And we're done, we've just solved using a,
or at least approximated
a solution using graphing
in a graphing calculator.